*Cris de Squeezie*
Vous savez ce que cette extinction de lumière signifie ?
Soit que j'ai fait une blague de merde, soit que c'est un épisode d'Outlast 2
Nous revoici dans le jeu, souvenez vous ici
Notre amour, l'amour de notre vie s'était fait enlevé bien sûr
Et on avait découvert qu'il y avait deux camps :  les chrétiens et des mecs chelous
dont un qui s'est fait démolir la gueule par la femme qui est venue
me lécher littéralement le visage
Ça va être la panique, je peux bien vous le dire, ça va être la grosse panique
On va devoir s'infiltrer dans des maisons pour retrouver notre femme, voilà
Par exemple les bâtiments que l'on voit là bas
Oh putain, mec
Ça fout la frousse
Comme on dit, quand on est un peu plus vieux que moi
Vous pouvez vous cacher en vous accroupissant sous l'eau ?
Et la caméra elle est waterproof du coup
Pour regarder furtivement, maintenez "a" ou "e"
oh c'est malin, ça ! il y a personne, pourquoi je me cache
ah mais si il y a un mec ! putain mais d'entrée de jeu, quoi...
Ouais donc OK. Donc on va se déplacer derrière ce caillou
Putain je me déplace lentement sous l'eau
Allez va derrière le caillou
oh putain
C'est long mais on peut le faire
J'ai confiance en mes capacités
On est bien là ou pas ?
Il est où ? Il est où ?
Il est plus là ?!
Mec ! What the fuck ! Oh là c'est la panique ! Attendez je me relève
Wow le mec a disparu !
Ah ouais nan OK il a pas tant disparu que ça finalement
Bah attends, c'est le moment d'y aller, en tout cas, très clairement
Alors. Est-ce qu'on peut pas passer par ces hautes herbes ?
On se déplace vraiment lentement, mec quand on est... oh putain...
Alors il faudrait attendre qu'il passe et qu'il aille là-bas pour qu'on puisse passer bien évidemment.
Bien évidemment... Ah ok  en fait il y a un mec en face
Putain... Mec si je me fais repérer ça va être tellement la panique...
Ah mais ils reviennent en fait ! Ah mais en fait il faut que j'y aille maintenant vas-y mec, hein nique sa mère.
Nique sa mère mais faut y aller maintenant
Ptain ce qui me fait chier c'est les autres, là ils éclairent partout !
Par où je peux passer ici ?
Ici je peux pas passer ici ? nan clairement pas
Ok je vais aller dans l'eau
Ouvre ouvre ouvre !
Wow c'est quoi ça encore ! C'est l'espèce de phare qui s'était allumé et qui aveugle...
What ?
Oh nan ça c'était dans la démo par contre ! Et ça m'avais pas plu du tout !
Oh nan...
Ouais qu'est-ce que... Qu'est-ce que...
Blake: "Je rêve, ou j'ai perdu la tête" !
C'est l'espèce de flash là qui rend tout le monde fou, qui me rend moi-même fou, en fait ?
C'est ça je crois
Blake lit : " Je suis désolée de devoir faire ça.
Tu aurais dû m'aimer.
Tu aurais dû m'aider.
Bon sang, pardonne-moi, je ne sais pas quoi faire
Je suis tellement désolée. Jessica."
Squeezie : D'accord
Ok
Euh... Et on a une photo
Blake : "Jessica et Lena.
Comme nous étions...
La classe de musique??"
Putain
What the fuck ?
Blake : "Merde! Je suis de retour en 4ème!"
Mais si ça pourrait aller plus mal j'te jure que tu verras plus tard dans le jeu tu reviendras sur ce que t'as dit là
Quand ça ira bien plus mal
Ouais alors attends on peut pas... Ok...
On se retrouve une nouvelle fois dans... dans ce putain de couloir glauque, mec !
Oh la la la la la la...
C'est terrible... ce couloir est terrible...
Ça me fout le cafard... Même l'ambiance des écoles américaines
Ch'ais pas pourquoi ça me fout le cafard... et en plus il y a un mec là-bas
C'est un vrai mec ou c'est genre une illusion ? Ou c'est un mec qui va vraiment nous chasser ?
Nan..
Ok faut que j'aille à droite à mon avis. Alors on va aller à droite, hein ?
Et on va fermer ça bien comme il faut derrière nous !
Oh nan...
Oh oui j'ai une pile
Comment je la prends ?
Wow ! Oh mais nan mais là mec je vais me faire démolir
Mais putain ça m’oppresse de ouf cette télé ! Passe !
Oh... Si il rentre je suis foutu mec...
Si il rentre je suis juste mort... Mais vraiment, hein ?
C'est pas la petite mort ! Allez prends la pile !
Tout ça pour une pile, mec... Sans déconner
Roh il va être là... On parie combien il va être là ?
Il campe toujours là-bas ! C'est encore pire
C'est encore pire j'aurai préféré qu'il soit là !
De toute façon en vrai je pense qu'il faut y allez , en vrai
(cri de surprise)
Oooooooh mon dieu !
Sa me re-tp et il est re là bas
Non ...
Non c'est bon c'est bon. Il est plus là je peux y aller.
Oh lala quand je cours le couloir s'allonge
Oh oui une sortie
J'peux pas ouvrir
Pourquoi?
Pourquoi vous me torturez l'esprit comme ça putain ?!
Bon bah mec , c'est là hein
Ouais , on passe par la sortie
Qu'est ce qui s'est passé en classe de 4ème?
Avec Jessica et Lynn , je me demande hein
En vrai le mec dit que c'est la pire année pourquoi il s'est passé quoi
Le froid
avec la neige j'vois rien c'est terrible
On va allez tout droit hein
Qu'est ce qu'on fout là quoi?
Ah ptite porte qui s'ouvre c'est pour nous
Ah! Et là on est de retour dans la
dans la vraie vie, hors du cauchemar
On sait pas ce qui s'est passé , on a eu un flash , on est devenu fou on sait pas ce qui s'est passé
*étonnement*
"C'est vous, pas vrai?
L'étranger
L'oeil de Loth, ils vous ont tué pas vrai?"
"Non."
"Pas encore."
"Eh ben ils le feront si ils vous trouvent ici!"
"Venez!"
UN AMI !
On s'est fait un ami !
Ethan "Je m'appelle Ethan"
Blake : "Etes-vous l'un deux?"
Ouah je suis complétement désorienté a cause de la lumière
Ethan : "Je suis...encore un être"
"J'en ai trop vu pour garder la foi"
Blake : "Mais vous n'êtes pas avec les autres hein?
Les hérétiques"
Ethan : "J'ai rien dit quand ma femme a eu la gale,
on a dû la chasser."
Squeezie : Ouaaah
Ethan : "J'ai rien dit quand Loth,
s'est couché sur ma ptite Nathalie
elle a à peine 15 ans"
Ooooh
Ethan : " Mais quand il a voulu mon p'tit fils,
le bébé qu'il a planqué dans le ventre de ma fille,
qui devait être l'Antéchrist
j'ai dû l'éventrer et tuer l'enfant."
(cris de dégout de Squeezie)
c'est ce qui ce passe avec notre fe... notre femme à nous,avec Lynn non ?
Nan?
ces maux de ventre et tout là
Raah putain mec , c'est chelou je suis à la fois content et
vraiment pas content de rencontrer ce mec
j'ai vraiment l'impression qu'à tout moment il peut nous planter et nous trahir, nan?
Ethan :" Je lui ai donné une chance de s'enfuir,
j'ai baratiné ces crétins.
J'ai toujours su quoi dire
Vous avez p'tetre déjà remarqué"
"Votre fille...
Squeezie : "Ooh c'est la meuf
qui a été retrouvée étranglée sur la route"
Ethan : "qu'est ce que vous savez?
Vous l'avez vue?"
"C'est pour elle que nous sommes venus ici"
Ethan : "Est-ce qu'elle va bien? Je vous en prie...
Monsieur,
dites-moi qu'elle va bien !"
"Euh...elle va bien"
Ethan : "Dieu merci ! Oh dieu merci!"
Squeezie : Mais mec, il va apprendre qu'elle est morte
et il va m'en vouloir à moi de lui avoir dit qu'elle va bien
en même temps, cette situation tu veux faire quoi mec?
Si tu lui dis elle est morte, le mec te tue d'office !
C'est quoi ça ?
Ethan : "Vous vous êtes vraiment fendu la tête pas vrai?"
Squeezie : Ah! Je suis pas bien du tout
Mec
Ethan : "J'ai un lit en bas"
Squeezie : Euuuuh oui !
Oui oui comment dire euh! noop
Oh! Putain on a pas le choix on est obligé!
Non mais
Adieu, adieu à la vie !
Ethan : "Détendez-vous, je vais vous protéger"
(cri de peur de Squeezie)
Pardon mes amis je vous fais peur  pour rien
Ethan va s'occuper de vous
Ah, j'ai un max de bandage !
Comment je fais pour me bander? Ah je peux pas, j'ai plus accès a ma caméra,  j'ai plus rien !
C'est un peu glauque ici quand même!
mais au moins on est caché ! Vas-y je vais dormir.
On va se reposer, on va se raviver l'esprit
ça va nous faire du bien
Voilà! Dormons.
Comment tu veux?
En vrai tu dois faire la pire nuit de ta vie... Après ce qui vient de lui arriver
Voix : "S'il te plait, Blake,
ou es-tu?"
Squeezie : Encore ce cauchemar putain!
Voix "J'ai peur!
Nous ne sommes pas seuls!
Il arrive !
Ah ! Il est ici ! Vas-t'en vite! Aaaah"
Ethan : "Je ne cache rien"
"La vertu ne peut pas passer dans le sang par les reins,
mais par le sang de ton coeur"
Ethan: "J'connais bien l'évangile de papa
Je l'ai copiée 100 fois !
Si je savais où était l'étranger...
Voix : "Le prophète n'a pas besoin de toi pour trouver la putain du diable et son débauché"
Knoth interroge déjà d'autre hérétiques à la chapelle.
Dieu va le guider !
Non
(Bruits de bagarre)
Mais non mon seul ami, c'était si court comme connaissance  !
Comme relation, pardon !
Voix: "Tu as pêché lorsque tu as refusé ta fille au prophète!
Tu as péché depuis pour le nier
tu sais où est l'étranger!
Squeezie : Non non, il sait pas, il sait pas, il sait pas
Laisse le en paix, vraiment il sait pas
Dieu et le prophète veulent son sang!
Laisse moi parler a Knoth. Je peux tout expliquer.
Dieu n'écoute pas les morts !
(bruits glauques)
Oh putain, il s'est fait exploser!
Voix : "Bouge pas!"
(gargouillis)
Voix : "Fais pénitence!
Dieu t'aime !
J'en ai marre
J'en ai marre de cette ambiance, putain
(Bruits de lutte)
(Bruit de hache)
Je sais pas ce qu'elle lui a fait mec, mais quand on va revoir son corps, on va vraiment bader
Oh putain !
Ouais beh mec,
T'inquiète qu'il l'a bien retrouvée, il l'a bien bien bien retrouvée
Allez mec hein, c'est par où d'jà qu'on était venu ici ?
Putain de merde on est enfermé là quoi
Là par exemple on peut y aller par là non ?
Attend mais, c'était par où, ah c'est là
Alors, dans quel état il est ? Nickel !
Blake : "il a rien dit"
Ouais par contre c'est un bon pote
Merde
Merci mec, merci mec, franchement
Merci mec, voilà c'est enregistré
Blake : "Cette...femme!
Qui qu'elle soit, elle l'a battu à mort !
Elle voulait trouver Lynn
Quelque chose à propos d'une Chapelle
Bon beh mec ravi d'avoir fait ta connaissance
Ca t'auras coûté la vie mais bon tu as rejoint ta fille
D'ailleurs il va nous en vouloir quand il va voir qu'elle était morte
Il va nous en vouloir de lui avoir mytho
Il va se dire : "putain j'aurais pas dû protéger ce fils de chien"
Bon aller, on veut trouver Lynn
Et je parle pas du chocolat encore une fois
Parce qu'on adore cette blague, qu'elle nous rassure beaucoup
D'accord, faut faire le tour par l'eau
Alors on y va
OH
J'en ai marre
On va aller dans le bât.. Oh putain y a un mec...
Voix féminine : "Nous sommes la douleur de celle qui enfante
De cette tonnelle apparaissent les enfants de l'enfer."
Oh lala lala
Qu'est ce que tu fous ? Mais plonge, fais comme tout le monde, amuse-toi et on en parle plus quoi
Je peux passer par en dessous ou pas vous pensez
Vas-y on va tenter, on est des guerriers, on tente, on s'en bat les steaks
Oh lala lala lala Mais ils sont pas bien
Ils sont PAS bien du tout
Bon on va passer par là. On peut passer par là ou pas vous pensez
Faut faire le tour par la
Ok on va passer par là
Si on se fait griller mon gars, beh y a pas le choix d't'façon, en vrai y a pas le choix
Sauvegarde
Oh putain les champs mec
Hérétique
Pourquoi putain de merde ?
Pourquoi putain de merde j'ai pas compris
Oh merde, mon gars
N'oubliez pas que vous pouvez utiliser votre microphone pour entendre à travers les murs et suivre les bruits
On va devoir fuir on va devoir s'infiltrer mon gars
C'est fermé !
Vas y go !
MAIS JE SUIS BAISE
MAIS NON !
Ou alors on peut se cacher là. Mais je peux aller où ?
Ah beh là ! Y a un trou dans le barbelé putain le con
Oh ! Et y a un mec mort avec... D'accord !
Je suis dans les hautes herbes
Je suis couché
On lui a échappé, on lui a échappé Il est où ? Ho putain, il est où ?
Il est juste là
Mais où faut qu'on aille mec?! On voit rien dans cet endroit de mort !
Ok allons par là
J'y vais au pif
Me jugez pas, hein
Ok là on commence à apercevoir un truc ou deux
Est-ce qu'il y a du monde ? On va se fier par apport aux bruits
Ok, il y en a un derrière moi là bas
Est-ce qu'il y a du monde vers là, là bas
Non, on peut y aller
OH MERDE
MERDE
ÇA M'AIDE PAS DU TOUT
Donc ok ... Ok on va longer la clôture c'est une bonne idée
IL Y A UNE PILE
PUTAIN INCROYABLE !
Il y a un mec
Il y avait un mec
Je m'allonge, il est juste à côté mec !
Wouaaah il a faillit me griller !
Il est juste là !
On part par où par la gauche ?
Oh il est juste là ce batard !
Leave me alone
Moi, j'pense il faut longer les côtés
En longeant les côtés mec
On trouvera le chemin à suivre
Ah !
Est-ce que c'est pas par là ? SI C'EST PAR LÀ
TU M'AURAS PAS
IL M'A VU MAIS JE M'EN BAS LES STEACKS JE SUIS PASSÉ
Oh merde
Ok, on l'a esquivé
ALLER
OH LES BATARDS
C'EST HORRIBLE CETTE SITUATION
C'est bon aller go ! On est dans la grange on est bien !
On est bien
ON EST PAS BIEN DU TOUT
On est mort ...
J'suis mort
Nan c'est fermer ! NAAAAN
*Cris de Squeezie*
NON LAISSÉ MOI EN PAIX PARDON
J'AI RIEN FAIS
J'AI JAMAIS VOULU TOUT ÇA !
soigne-toi à temps
in the head
head shot, il m'a mis un gros head shot !
ho non j'ai paniqué dans la grange. On va les attirés dehors
pour revenir
et fermer la porte. Ça marchera jamais
Ok il est sorti
Il va aller jusqu'où, c'est ça la question
Ça en fait un de moins dans la truc. C'est très bien ça. Ok go maintenant
pffff, yes je m'suis jamais senti aussi bien d'être en hauteur mec
Ho putain
non c'est bon. Nan nan c'est pas bon
nan y a un mec mort j'ai vu un mec mort
on a eu une hallucination
non, y a bien un mec mort, en foetus. Ça fait quoi ça non mais tire pas
si tu sait pas ce que ça fait !
"gémissement de squeezie"
j'me casse, tombe pas j'ten supplie
saut de l'ange à l'Assassin's Creed
on est bien, on est bien
on est bien c'est rien, c'est rien, c'est des cadavres, c'est du sang, y a le même dans tes veines
c'est rien, c'est rien, ça va aller. aller on dégage, on s'en va très très loin d'ici
mais tellement loin mec
je ne saurais vous dire où nous allons nous rendre
ho ce truc est... Ho mais mec
on dirai... j'ai cru que cétait un vrai mec. Ho ya une page ya une page
âme du christ prépare-moi, Père Knoth guide mon salut, Sang du christ, laisse moi boire ton vin
Ça dégage, ça dégage j'men bat les couilles, jm'en vais
Il y avait un bidon pour se cacher, vous savez se que ça veut dire, ça veut dire
qu'il y a des gens qui vont arriver d'en face
c'est un mec ou pas ? c'est un mec ou c'est un spot... non c'est un spot fixe
c'est un piège ça, c'est un spot fixe, ok, holalalala
arrêtez avec ce flash
ho ça a niqué tous les oiseaux
heu y a un mec mort
encore un mec mort...et le pont est pété, le pont est pété
il doit y avoir un autre accès, tu es sérieux
Là ! Je l'ai trouvé l'autre accès. Il va mener vers des trucs
encore plus glauques mon gars soyez'en sûr
Lynn
Mon amour ?
allez on monte
on peut pas monter par là ?
ok on peut bien monter par quelque part c'est évident
par où je ne sais pas, mais faut monter... ok par là, allez
ho mec
allez on y va on y va
je peux aller par la ? Non ? Faire le grand saut ?
UNE PILE, j'men bat les couilles du saut, y a une pile en bas
Mec, sa ça va nous servir plus-tard, vous allez voir, sa va être terrible
allez let's go
allez plus vite n'ai pas peur, si tu tombe sa ne fera qu'une cheville cassée
finalement une cheville cassée quand tu es entouré de 10 milles ennemis c'est quoi hein ?
C'est pas grand chose
ok on y est
on monte
putain mec ça va nous mener à un endroit encore pire
c'est évident
qu'est-ce-qu'on a ici ? Ha c'est par là
Ouais on a une grotte
ho putain on va tomber mec, sur une sorte de mec
qui était dans la même situation que nous il y a 3ans et qui est devenu fou tu sais
qui se nourrit de chair humaine depuis 10ans
Ho putain
ho la grotte je la sent pas du tout mec, la grotte je la sent pas du tout
OK
Ho merde
ho putain c'est beau
Ha ! Il tourne une vidéo, il a aussi trouvé ça beau
lui aussi, il fait un petit vlog avec cette statue
allez vas-y
ho non
ho non, non
on  voulait voir tous sauf ça
ho putain
c'est, ça va être un endroit terrible
ça va être un endroit terrible
Ils ont sacrifié un truc qui n'est pas un humain vu le crane
heum... ca par contre on peut dire que c'est des...
y a des bruits
bon allez cassons-nous cassons-nous pourquoi je perds du temps ici
faut qu'on se barre
allez, allez tu le fais tu le fais on dégage d'ici mec
plus vite que ça
crains de ouf
OK
ho la la la la c'est bien ça change d'ambiance c'est espèce de grotte
avec des bouts de bois partout mais je dit pas que c'est pas une bonne chose hein
bon c'est quand même une bonne chose en vrai, on voit plus rien d'accord
ok
Ho ! j'ai eu une hallucination, ho c'est super badan
alors ça c'est super badant
Putain j'ai cru que cétait Lynn mec voilà fin de let's play, fin du jeu
en vrai j'aurai été déçu. pour vous faufiler, déplacez-vous dans l'espace
ha la ok excuse-moi  très bien
OK
Ah il est
D'accord
D'accord d'accord les message de propagande faut plus qu'on les écoutes vraiment
Qu'est qu'il en pense ?
jouer
Je pouvait voir la chapelle. Ah donc c'est un élément important !
OK
Ok ok ok.  Aller c'est tipar !
La chapelle, ah il y a une corniche avant pardon
Ah mais en fait on va pas à la chapelle
rooh non mais mec si on va au milieu de ce village on est foutu mec on vas ce faire traquer direct
c'est évident
ça va de soi
on est bon ?
Allo ?
Ok c'est bon
Alors où faut aller ?
Ok on descend. Eh bah si on va à la chapelle mec putain
Mais je pense c'est un élément important à mon avis Lynn elle est là bas à mon avis
on va pas ce mentir
Y a des lights ouais c'est pas des torches d'un mec, oh putain on va ce faire
On est pas les seuls ici c'est ca ?
Oh putain on n'est pas les seules ici, ca va de soit
Ok
Ok on est dans la maison d'un mec qui a créé son petit sanctuaire
A bases, notamment, de cadavres
Ah ! Une note !
"D'autres enfants morts. Knoth dit qu'il n'y a aucun péché dans ces infanticides
Car ils sont tous des soldats de l'armée de Dieu.
Des martyrs tombés sur le champ de bataille pour défier le démon."
Oui ! "Tous ces bébés à la gorge tranchée, à la chair carbonisée
nous attendront, immaculé, au paradis" Oui bien sûr, bien évidemment
P*tain
Je ne sais pas sur quoi on va tomber, mec, mais...
Ca va être très très mauvais
Ok ! Un mec mort
Est- ce qu'il va nous faire flipper ? Est-ce qu'il est encore un peu vivant ? Non, on dirait pas
OK, faut monter encore ou il faut se barrer ?
C'est barricadé, on ne peut que monter, alors montons
"de tuer votre enfant"
Bah, un peu quand même ! Un peu ! J'espère bien que si ton Dieu, il te dit de tuer ton enfant, tu le détestes
P*tain
"Sullivan, Papa
Ezékiel Menteur, Charlatan. Temple de la goutte. Toxicomane
Lâche.Violeur. Tueur d'enfants. Je suis parti, et j'ai pris avec moi tous ceux
qui avaient le courage de voir la vérité. Viens nous chercher.Viens nous traquer. Nous attendons,
et sommes prêts à tuer et baiser tous ceux que tu enverras au sommet de la montagne."
God damn it p*tain
Oh mon Dieu ! C'est pas le moment de jouer un peu de guitare
Finalement, pour se détendre
Ah bah si ! Regarde ça mec, sa cache une porte ! J'avais pas vu !
Je suis demeuré
P*tain, mec ! La pression de cet épisode est palpable, quoi !
Terrible !
Allez !
Faut sauter, hein !
J'ai vu un mec, j'ai vu un mec passé, ok là...
Là on est en terrain dangeureux
Ou en "terrain connu", Terre Inconnue, jeu de mots
Vous avez compris, excellent ! Oh Yes !
Oh p*tain !
Effectivement mec ! J'espère aussi !
On est dans la m*rde, on est dans la grosse m*rde on va pas se mentir ! ON EST JUSTE DANS L'ENORME M*RDE !
Ou est le générateur ?
Oh non.....non !
Cet ambiance, elle est malsaine mais à un point. Alors, un générateur !
Ou serait le générateur à votre avis ?
Oh p*tain !
Le mec attend à sa p*tain de fenêtre, mec !
Mais j'en peux plus !
C'est tellement flippant ! Bein, il est peut-être la en fait, juste là, dans celle-là
En vrai
Sur quoi on va tomber, mec ? Sur quoi on va tomber, mec !
Pour le moment, il n'y a rien de mal
On a bientôt plus de pile mais c'est pas grave, on en a ramassées plein
Alors, peut-être en passant par cette maison en bas, on peut esquiver la ligne droite où il y a tout le monde
Je sais pas, je propose , hein ! Oh, c'est fermé ! On est mal
Oh ne me dis pas que c'est une maison qui ne sert à rien !
C'est une p*tain de maison.... ! Il y a au moins une pile ! Au moins, une pile, tu vois
Qu'elle n'ait pas servi complètement à rien
Non, mec ! On peut bien se mettre un doigt dans le cul !
On peut bien bien se mettre un doigt dans le cul !
Très bien. AH ! Par la fenêtre, peut-être, du coup
Ah, regardez ! Il y a peut-être un spot là
Ca sert à rien ce que j'ai fait
P*tain la meuf se balade maintenant ! Le mec, il est toujours à sa fenêtre ou pas ?!
Non, il s'est barré
Rooh lalalalalala
Alors, ah ! Par là, regardez, il y a un chemin !
Attend, je vais changer la pile
C'est bon !
Pile changée, on est bien ! On est serein !
Vas-y mec on va-y aller en avançant.
Ahh regardez! voilà j'crois qu'on la trouvé.
Rooh putain lui il l'avait trouvé aussi apparemment.
Et ensuite il faut passer quand il s'avance, j'pense.
Aller avance toi, avance toi comme ça je passe.
Faut qu'elle avance sinon on passera pas.
J'crois en faite elle est folle. J'pense qu'elle va réciter son truc même si je passe devant elle.
Bon y'a qu'un moyen de le savoir les gars.
Ok j'avais raison.
Génial. J'avais parfaitement raison.
Alors attendez. Toujours regardez où sont les héré.. oh un mec qui brûle c'est très gay, très très gay ça.
Vraiment .. NONN
NON god fucking damn it
Ok j'suis caché.
*cris*
Tu m'auras pas.
C'est évident c'est là haut.
Ils sont partout, ils sont partout. J'en peux plus.
Pause.Pause.
J'vais me bander pendant que j'suis là.
Ok.
Aller. On peut pas se bander pendant qu'on est là. Nickel.
Caméra.
Attends j'me suis mal mis. Y'a quelqu'un ?
Quelqu'un qu'est là ?
La pression level 6 milliards.
Y'en avait 2 à droite, juste là plus loin
Un en bas à gauche, qui est en train de monter probablement...
Parce qu'il m'a vu partir en courant d'une maison dans laquelle, il m'a mit une grosse droite.
Il va pas m'oublier comme ça.
Contrairement à ce qu'on pense.
Ohh ma montre est cassée. C'est probablement la chose la plus triste de...
de ce jeu. Aller on y va.
Ok
Scred.
J'fais pas un bruit mec.
Putain j'dis ça, on fait carrément du bruit .
Le générateur il est où ? Y'a pas un câble, un truc qui me permet de le trouver
Je sais pas moi.
Quand j'vais allumer ça va faire...
C'est l'générateur.
Oh bon dieu.
J'ai trouvé le générateur, j'ai trouvé une note avec même si ça on s'en fou un peu.
Siméon, je dois te parler dans le plus grand secret car tu t'y connais en onguents et autres médicaments.
J'espère que tu sais que je n'échange pas plus de mots que tes soeurs lorsque nous visitons,
Le monde damné pour aller acheter de l'essence, des composants électriques,
et tout ce dont nous avons besoin, que nous ne pouvons pas faire nous mêmes.
C'est tellement glauque.
C'est trop bien cette ambiance.
Alors on l'a vu c'est parti.
Ca va tous les attirer.
T'inquiète, mec je sais parfaitement où faut aller pour trouver l'ascenseur.
*cris de peur*
Oh la pute.
Oh la...
Pute..
Raccourci.
Ahh
Ta gueule, ferme ta putain de gueule, ferme ta putain de gueule.
Ohh y'a un raccourci !
Ahh
J'peux pas passer par là.
Ohh la douille
C'est pas grave.
J'me met un bandage avant,  parce que j'me suis fais mal.
J'ai plus de bandages, c'est pas grave.
C'est pas grave. C'est hyper grave, mais on va dire que c'est pas grave.
Eh mec là faut y aller.
C'est maintenant qu'y faut foncer, comme jamais.
Esquive latérale
Elle one shot mec ! Ok, elle...
C'est par là qu'on est venu tout à l'heure, ouais ! Ok, c'est par là
Passe, passe, passe Salaud !!
Ok on est bien
En fait, j'ai plus de sprint, en fait. J'suis épuisé, oh putain
On va se cacher dans les herbes, le temps de régénérer
Elle sait pas ou j'suis sinon elle cheat
Là on est bien
Elle est juste là-bas, ok ! On va attendre vite fait !
Ouais, ouais, ouais, ouais, ouais
Oh j'ai envie de vomir tellement ça m'a mis la pression
Horrible !
Ok on est bon ! Ou on va atterrir ?!
Ok, dans le pire endroit du monde
Dans le pire endroit du monde...
Avec ce truc qui est dans 100% des films et jeux d'horreur de la planète
Il n'y a personne ici, on est en paix ! Y'a personne
"Gâre à ce que vous voyez, petits..." Il faut aller dans le puit ! On pari qu'il faut aller dans le puit
Qu'est-ce que c'est que ça, mec ?!?!
Ca c'est une hallucination ! En vrai, je suis juste tombé
Il n'y a pas une langue de géant qui est venue m'enrouler, mec ! Putain, c'est moi ou
Ils ont vraiment un problème avec les langues dans ce jeu ! Tantôt la meuf qui me lèche le visage et une langue géante qui m'enroule !
J'en ai marre, moi ! Oh Putain !
J'arrive, j'arrive !
Ca me stresse tellement
J'arrive ! Je vais avoir des boutons demain !
Me revoilà en cours putain !
Oui, j'ai cru comprendre, ouais ! J'ai vraiment bien compris !
Quoi, il arrive ? Moi je veux me casser ! Je cours !
Non, j'suis enfermé !
Non ! Tout s'est ouvert ! Il y a re le casier de Jessica !
C'est quoi ça ?! Une boite à outil ?! On prend la boite à outil ! Ca c'était dans la démo, je m'en souviens !
Oh mon Dieu ! La pression est à son comble à la fin de cet épisode !
Ok, qu'est-ce que ça va faire ?!
Ca nous a fait du bien, un peu de musique !
Mec, j'suis sûr, il y a quelqu'un !
Non, c'est bon, ok
Ouais, moi aussi, moi aussi ! M'en parle pas, m'en parle pas parce que je me chie dessus
C'est quoi ! Pourquoi la caméra, elle devient brouillée ?! Ok, lumière, lumière, lumière !!!
Lumière ! Restons calme !
Bah, je retourne là-bas, mec ! Oh la pute !
Jess !
Ok elle est là !
C'est comme dans la démo. Oh putain !
On a re la vision de Jess pendue
Et les mains !
Ok c'est là
Oh Putain ! On dirait la maison de Resident Evil 7 !!
Qué pasa ?!
Es la hora dès
Je sais même pas... je... j'sais pas où je vais
Oh putain mais il y a des gens morts partout ! C'est une usine à morts !
"N'oubliez pas que vous pouvez verrouiller les portes" Ok je la verrouille !
Hòpla ! DTC ! Dtc Fdp !
Oh putain, on perd du temps sur une porte fermée, j'ai tellement le seum mec !!
C'est par où ?!?! Mais c'est par où ?!?!
Ah là, ok, il y a un trou !
Vamos !
On est en train de ramper, il ne saura pas qu'on est là !
J'ai le flair pour ces choses ! Il nous trouvera JAMAIS !
Oh put... Quoi ! Il y a une lampe là ?!
C'est un mec qui regarde ?!
IL RAMPE !
J'SUIS BLOQUE !
Non c'est bon, il y avait un autre chemin !
J'avais jamais vu ça !
Même dans les conduits, on est pas tranquille, vous vous rendez compte un peu !
Vous vous rendez compte un peu !
Le mec rampait !
Ok, on est de retour là !
Oh ! Ooooh !!!
J'suis mort ! J'suis mort ! J'prend la pile avant de mourir !
Hop ! C'était une feinte en fait !
J'suis mort mec ! J'suis foutu ! J'suis foutu ! Je sais pas où il faut aller
Non mais mec, faut faire quoi là ?!
Faut aller où ? Faut aller où ? Aller, on garde notre clame !
Oui, c'est peut-être dans la maison qui est en face là ! Il y a une porte ouverte, mec ! Ca m'étonnerait pas que ce soit par là en fait !
En vrai
Il y a un verrou ou pas ? Il n'y a pas de verrou sur cette porte ! Nick... si, il y a un verrou !
Ok c'est verrouillé !
Foutez moi la paix maintenant ! Ouais, je pense que c'est par là !
Ouais !
Non mais il va... Il pète les bouts de bois là !!
Ok il pète les bouts de bois, d'accord ! C'est juste mal fait, merde !
Ouais !
Ouais, ouais
J'suis mort. Je peux pas me cacher sous le lit, il y a des obstacles ! NON !
Mec, dis moi quoi faire !
AAAAH !!!
Ok, à mon avis, il fallait juste se cacher sous un lit, en fait !
Mais j'ai pas eu le réflexe assez tôt. Et là, normalement, il nous trouvera pas !
Ca marche !
Ah mais mec, putain ! Je vous ai dit en plus dans le 1er épisode, faut que je chope les réflexes !
Ok on se casse !
Oh putain, c'est tellement bien fait ! Ils te font changer de décisions en cours de route, quoi !
On verrouille toujours derrière nous, comme ça on est bien
Je peux aller par où là ?!
Nul part
Il n'y a nul part où aller. Je peux que me cacher dans le placard. Attend, on va y aller aux bruits !
Il y a un mec qui es juste de l'autre côté là !
Il est juste de l'autre côté, je peux pas y aller maintenant. Faut que j'attende !
C'est terrible ! Terrible !
Il est là ! Il est juste là, vous l'avez vu ?
On va attendre vite fait, qu'il parte
Ok, Go !
En fait, le blême c'est qu'il fallait la pousser dans l'autre sens, l'étagère, putain !
C'est pour ça que tout à l'heure on s'est fait baisé ! C'est pas que quand il a peur, il pousse plus !
C'est que je l'ai poussé dans le mauvais sens, mec ! J'ai tellement pas de chance ! Allez, on dégage !
On s'en va d'ici, on prend la fuite ! C'est fini ?
Putain, mec ! Ca.. c'est... j'suis....
Je n'ai jamais été tendu pendant aussi longtemps !
Je vais recharger la pile ! Je l'use vraiment bien jusqu'à la fin ! C'est qui ?
C'est une... c'est ma.... non c'est pas elle !
C'est pas elle putain ! Sinon il aurait dit quelque chose !
A moins que !
Non c'est pas elle ! C'est pas elle !
Je sais pas qui c'est ! Bon ! Bah, les amis, on va le découvrir
dans le prochain épisode ! Je pense qu'on a assez joué pour cet épisode !
N'hésitez pas à aimer la vidéo si ça vous a plu comme d'habitude !
Ca me motive carrément à faire le reste du jeu
Même si je suis déjà surmotivé de base pour ce jeu-là, je ne vais pas vous mentir
Mais bon, ça me fait toujours plaisir de voir que c'est apprécié et que ça vous plait
Et puis, je vous dit à très vite dans une prochaine vidéo et dans un prochain épisode dans 2 jours !
Heureusement que je met du bon déo parce que là mon gars
Tu vois la Seine ? A Paris ? Et bein, elle serait là comme ça !
Allez, merci d'avoir regardé ! Portez-vous bien ! Au revoir !